from to flash people are going to die
and that's going to be on I've made a
few slight modifications as captains
although would think
how's it go
[Music]
he youtubers is Charlie congratulations
for surviving comic-con
we got all kinds of Flash stuff to break
down Grant Gustin even talked about the
evolve very Alan that's coming out of
the Speed Force there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway and I have about
four winners that I need to name from
Comic Con at the end of this video so a
crazy amount of stuff was announced they
confirm the cast member we found out
who's going to be playing The Thinker we
found out that Danny Trejo is going to
be playing breacher gypsies father from
earth 19 Cisco's making this really
excited face because he's probably a
Danny Trejo band and himself at
the same time Grant Gustin was talking
about how the Speed Force is going to
change and evolve very going forward he
actually said some really cool stuff
they always try not to spoil things when
they do big interviews but he actually
said some really cool stuff that
hopefully they'll be able to follow up
on in the writing like they have good
pitches at the beginning of the season
but it remains to be seen how well that
plays out during the actual episodes
because they're currently working on
episode three right now I think they
just finished episode two or they're
finishing episode two so just to start
off with the big stuff first Barry
coming back people are wondering about
the trailer this being the future flash
costume like maybe this is Barry because
it looks like his belt is yellow instead
of red like it normally is Grant Gustin
did confirm that he is in the first
episode but not to like the very end in
just a little bit so I still think that
most of what we see in the trailer with
the red suit running around isn't
actually Barry it's still Wally wearing
Barry's suit and even though you can't
actually get a clear picking the blurry
face here like you can't tell whether
this barrier wallet but the main reason
why people think this is the flash is
because they see this bright yellow
looking belt here but the problem with
that is that right before you see this
subway scene with him running around the
train here you see him running past this
big 18-wheeler and it seems like it's
the same person in the belt is red so
there's one of two things happening here
this scene is completely different and
has absolutely nothing to do with this
scene right here like this is Wally and
then this is from like way at the end
the episode with Barry coming out of the
Speed Force and saving the day at the
end of the episode and some big twists
or when they were making this trailer
they're just a small error in the CG so
that the belt looks like it's yellow and
it's really just the same old suit that
they've always been wearing now I do
think that the flash suit will get some
minor upgrades but people are calling
this the future flash suit I think when
you really look at it this is not a good
look like the yellow on yellow I feel
like there's a much better version of
this that they could make so I think
he'll get closer to this suit like the
suit will change a slightly different
shade of red but I feel like they can do
a lot better like you won't run out of
the Speed Force automatically wearing
the new flash costume so just remember
it's still totally possible that this is
Barry and he is wearing the future flash
costume but also remember that there's
always minor CG errors continuity errors
TV shows surprise surprise from start to
finish make a lot of errors that get
ironed out by the time the final episode
airs so even though this looks like this
is finished footage they're going to
continue to polish this before the
episode airs in a couple months my main
takeaway from all the behind the scenes
of the first episode in what Qingyun
Lonsdale has been saying about his
character is that Wally is not a team
leader when the season picks up but he's
going to have this big step up moment
where he throws down I think that's what
episode 1 is all about and then also
bringing Barry back at the very end so
the Grant Gustin is around for the
entirety of episode 2 so as much as
they're bringing Barry back in this
episode I think it's more about Wally
stepping up and growing as a person like
that's when he finally puts on Barry's
costume but Grant Gustin talking about
the Speed Force this was actually one of
the coolest things that came out of the
flash panel at Comic Con the way the
Speed Force this time we're not going to
necessarily see Barry's experience in
the Speed Force we'll see kind of the
effects that the Speed Force has had on
Barry and he's been in there six months
real time but the way I see it as the
Speed Force is kind of nonlinear with
time so Barry is experienced kind of his
entire life from start to end infinity
times over since he's been in there so
he's going to have kind of an awakening
when he comes out he's going to be I
think he's got some knowledge that he
probably doesn't even quite
understand yet he'll also be a little
scrambled you won't really be himself
the first time we see him so I think
what they're doing is they're using this
time in the speedforce
to make a soft reset of his character
make him more mature he won't come out
making the same mistakes that he's made
the past couple of seasons he'll be more
of a team leader you'll see less of the
interpersonal politics that
you've seen previous seasons anytime a
character goes through like a big
crucible like that and then comes out
six months later is a really easy way
for the writers to dramatically advance
character development so Barry comes out
a much more badass version of Barry
Allen so on that same coin the main
villain thinker is going to be played by
Neil salyanz' from the 100 now I don't
watch the 100 but he sounds like he's
going to be a lot more fun a little bit
more mature a little more experienced so
I think he'll be a better foil than
Grant Gustin playing an emo version of
himself against his regular version of
Barry they've said that thinkers big
plan is to correct what he sees as the
fundamental problems of humanity that
reads a little bit like techno-organic
solution like he's is going to try and
turn everybody into drones matrix-style
or force some crazy evolution where
everybody all over the planet is
affected so they've also confirmed that
his helper character the mechanic the
person who develops all of his
technology is going to be played by Kim
Engelbrecht I'm not super familiar with
that actress but she's only supposed to
be a recurring guest star so she's not
going to be in every single episode the
thinker will be a series regular so
presumably we'll meet him by episode two
and it sounds like he's going to be the
person behind this Sam right here you've
also probably heard that tom Felton is
not going to be a serious regular and
has no plans to come back on the show as
of yet that doesn't mean that he won't
show up at all but for the most part no
Julian in season four they didn't really
say what's going on why he's not coming
back
I think it'll wind up being anything
where he comes back at least once a
season but I don't think they're going
to pursue that relationship with Kaitlyn
I think it just sounds like behind the
scenes the character didn't work out the
way they wanted him to tom felton is
fine I'm totally cool with tom Felton is
an actor but I wasn't the hugest fan of
the Julian character now they promised
us
dr. alchemy we didn't get anything close
to dr. alchemy in the Julien character
didn't really blend well with the
characters in STAR Labs like he had a
couple funny moments but I think he was
sort of meant to fill that gap that
Harrison wells from earth-2 used to fill
because he's the gruff person that
insulted people but was also kind of
nice at the same time that kind of felt
like what they were using the Julien
character for and it felt like they
forced the relationship with Caitlin I
never felt any kind of chemistry between
those characters so usually when stuff
like that happens they just quietly
assure the character away but if you're
one of the many draco malfoy fangirls
who's really upset he's not on the show
anymore don't worry it'll be fine and he
wasn't the thing that made last season
of the flash it's really the core
characters and I'm more happy that
they're doubling down on them then
trying to introduce some sort of gimmick
casting like hey you like Harry Potter
look we got an actor from Harry Potter
they made Harry Potter references a long
time before Harry Potter actors ever
came on the show so it's not that big a
deal he'll come back for a guest spot in
the future but what'll happen is they'll
continue to announce new characters that
they're casting new storylines that are
doing there'll be a couple more promos
for episode 1 so if there are any bonus
videos you guys want me to do just let
me know in the comments what's going to
happen next is is they dropped a whole
bunch of bombs about arrow season 6 so
there's a whole bunch of Deathstroke
stuff a whole bunch of new characters
Richard Ragan is going to be the main
villain from the comics so I'm really
excited about that
that trailer will be my next video so
I'll post that in a couple hours
if I have time also do some more Comic
Con trailers I also have Young Justice
season 3 to do so hopefully I'll be able
to finish all my Comic Con videos by
Friday there's still a bunch of stuff I
had to skip over congratulations to all
the Comic Con DC giveaway winners Finn
Bowden karate six one nine glitch roar G
and cube S key please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details I'll announce
the next winner when I post that arrow
video in a couple hours while you wait
for everything click here to re-watch
that flash season 4 trailer and you can
click here for the trailer for the next
episode of Game of Thrones thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight